FDX founder Sam bankman free charged
with bribe in Chinese officials this is
a Wall Street Journal
story uh he has been accused of
prosecutors of conspiring to bribe
Chinese government officials to Reign
access to over billion dollars in Frozen
cryptocurrency which violated the U.S
anti-corruption law Bank been freed
authorized the payment of at least 40
million dollars in cryptocurrency to one
or more of Chinese government officials
after months of failed attempts to
regain control of the accounts according
to the indictment Bank
bankman freed directed Alameda employees
to pay the bribe and he authorized an
additional payment of ten tens of
millions of dollars to complete the
bribe Alameda use the unfrozen crypto to
fund additional trades as bankman freed
uh Freed's Direction Tom
is anybody now surprised how all of
those Democrat congressmen and senators
were dead silent when this guy got
arrested and when this thing went down
do you remember the pictures of him
walking across the floor Congress and
Maxine Waters standing up on a chair or
a little dice there and blowing him
kisses literally blowing him kisses if
that's not scary enough to pull that up
and and you look at what's going on and
then they were all silent and this this
guy was this guy was a was a bribery
machine this was a Ponzi scheme and that
he had already he knew what was going on
and he was covering himself with
donations and bribes I don't know why
anybody is surprised and so why is
everybody surprised that the only guy
that was interrupted at the microphone
was the prosecutor on this none of the
politicians have you notice how quiet
they were
it's because I I I I need to be on
vacation
all of them and that's Maxine Waters
when she was the chairperson chairman of
the house
chairman of the house Financial Services
committee that tells you everything who
was the number one contributor to the
Democrat Party after George Soros it was
a FDX right it tells you a lot so if you
like this clip and you want to watch
another one click right here and if you
want to watch the entire podcast click
right here
[Music]